currently I think they're eight
intelligences that I'm very confident
about and a few more that I've been
thinking about and I'll share that with
our audience the first two intelligences
are the ones which IQ tests and other
kind of standardized tests valorize and
as long as we know there are only two
out of eight it's perfectly fine to look
at them linguistic intelligence is how
well you're able to use language it's a
kind of skill that poets have other
kinds of writers journalists tend to
have linguistic intelligence had ardors
the second intelligence is logical
mathematical intelligence as the name
implies logicians mathematicians
scientists have that kind of
intelligence they're able to do
mathematical proofs they're able to do
scientific reasoning and experimentation
and it's great to have language and
logical intelligence because most tests
really focus on that and if you do well
in those tests as long as you stay in
school you think you're smart but if you
ever walk out onto Broadway or highway
or into the woods or into a farm you
then find out that other intelligences
are at least this important
so if third intelligences musical
intelligence and that's the capacity to
appreciate different kinds of musics to
produce the music by voice or by an
instrument or to conduct music and
people say well musics a talent it's not
an intelligence and I say well why if
you're good with words is that in
intelligence but if you're good with
tones and rhythms and Tambor's and
nobody's ever going to be good answer
which is why it makes sense to talk
about musical intelligence and in
certain cultures over history musical
intelligence has been very important
a fourth intelligence is spatial
intelligence that's the intelligence
which allows us to handle and work in
space that's close by a chess player
would have spatial intelligence a
surgeon would have spatial intelligence
but there's another variety of spatial
intelligence which we use for much
broader navigation that's what an
airplane pilot or sea captain would
how do you find your way around large
territory and large space similarly with
the fifth intelligence bodily
kinesthetic intelligence it comes in two
flavors one flavor is the ability to use
your whole body to solve problems or to
make things and athletes and dancers
would have that kind of bodily
kinesthetic intelligence but another
variety is being able to use your hands
or other parts of your body to solve
problems or make things a crafts person
would have bodily kinesthetic
intelligence even if they weren't
particularly good athlete or dancer
sixth intelligence and seventh
intelligence have to do with human
beings interpersonal intelligence is how
you understand other people how you
motivate them how you lead them how you
work with them how you collaborate with
them anybody in any workplace with other
people needs interpersonal intelligence
leaders hopefully have a lot of
interpersonal intelligence but any
intelligence can be used in a pernicious
way so the salesmen that sells you
something you don't want for a price you
don't want to pay he or she is guide you
to personal intelligence it's just not
being used in a way that we might prefer
the seventh kind of intelligence is
difficult to assist but it's very
important it's intra personal
intelligence it's understanding yourself
if we go back way in history and
prehistory knowledge of yourself
probably wasn't that important because
people did what their parents and
grandparents did whether they were
hunters or fisherman or craftspeople but
nowadays especially in a developed
society people lead their own lives we
follow our own careers we often switch
careers we don't necessarily live at
home as we get older and if you don't
have a good understanding of yourself
you are in big trouble
so that's intrapersonal intelligence the
eighth intelligence which I added some
years ago is the naturalist intelligence
and that's the capacity to make
important relevant discriminations in
the world of nature between one plant
and another between one animal and
another it's the intelligence of the
naturalist intelligence of Charles
Darwin I missed it the first go-around
when I wrote about it but try to atone
by adding it to my list and by the way
you might say well nature isn't so
anymore but in fact everything we do in
the commercial world uses our naturalist
intelligence why do I buy this jacket
rather than another one this sweater
with another one is one hairstyle rather
another those all make use the
naturalist intelligence because the
brain is very adaptive and when an old
use of a brain Center no longer is
relevant it gets hijacked for something
new so we're all using our naturalist
intelligence even if we never walk out
into the woods or into the savanna of
East Asia there are two other
intelligences which I'm interested in
one of them is called the teaching or
pedagogical intelligence the
intelligence which allows us to be able
to teach successfully to other people
now you could have two people who have
exactly the same expertise and knowledge
in a field but one is a very good
teacher and the other isn't that
probably doesn't surprise individuals so
much but what got me fascinated was as
young as two or three kids already know
how to teach now what does that mean you
show a child how to do something let's
say a three or four year old and then
you ask the child to explain it to an
older person or to a younger person and
even the three or four year old will
explain it very differently to a young
person we'll go through details and
point things and speak slowly and when
older person will be much more
elliptical and say well you you do this
and that and then you can figure it out
so that shows as young as 3 let's say we
already have a teaching intelligence the
other one is one which I think is going
to be difficult to prove to a skeptic
but I call it existential intelligence
and the existential intelligence is the
intelligence of big questions
philosophical questions artistic
questions what does it mean to love why
do we die what's going to be in the
future
you know my my pet bird might have more
musical intelligence the rats are
scurrying around the floor might have
more spatial intelligence but no other
animals have existential intelligence
part of the human condition is to think
about questions of existence and I'd
like to say every five year old has
existential intelligence because
five-year-olds are always asking why
this why that but the difference between
a fight
year-old and a philosopher as the
five-year-old doesn't pay too much
attention to the answer
whereas philosophers and other people
who develop existential intelligence are
really very interested in how we attack
questions like that
so again whether there's eight
intelligences or ten or twelve is less
important to me than having broken the
monopoly of a single intelligence which
sort of labels you for all time I think
if we lived forever
we could probably develop each
intelligence to a very high degree but
life's very short and if you devote too
much attention to one intelligence
you're not going to have much time to
work on other kinds of intelligences and
so the big question is should you play
to strength or should you bolster
weakness and that's a value judgment
scientists cannot give you an answer to
that if for example you want to be a
jack-of-all-trades and be very well
rounded then probably you're going to
want to nurture the intelligences which
aren't that strong if on the other hand
you're dead set on really coming to the
top of some particular heap that you're
probably going to find the intelligences
that you're strongest at and really push
those and you know if the parent came to
me and said well should we supplement or
should we accentuate I would say well
tell me what you'd like your child to do
or better let the child tell you what he
or she wants to do rather than say well
science says you should do one with the
other I think it's a question of values
not of science
some people think there's such a thing
as humor intelligence but in fact I
don't I think humor intelligence is
simply the operation of the logical
intelligence in some realm like human
nature or physical nature or the
workplace and what happens is in humor
there's a certain expectation and you
flip that expectation so it's a it's
logic but it's a logic that's played out
in different kinds of ways people have
mentioned a there's such a thing as the
cooking intelligence humor intelligence
and sexual intelligence and I quipped
well they can't be intelligences because
I don't have any of them